we continue to grow super strong so we
're well over 300 million during this year
and we want to keep
growing so that's also why
we're building structures now and why
she's invested so far
welcome to the OMR podcast towards the end
of the year coming after mine  Gut feeling
probably one of the most surprising and
spectacular episodes of the year, my
guess is that at least two colleagues are sitting there,
one of whom recently took on a
different role from my podcast and the other
is probably we will be a
massive hidden champion, er,
welcome Chris Wolf and stefansmaler,
thank you very much for being here
Tell me what's the name of the company's
official group,
so to speak, but you don't know that, so
you know the brands you built
, there are exactly two brands,
mainly ESN and Mord
, they both grew separately, so
you don't know them in any way  the
background structures and  I think ESN is
so everyone who goes to the gym in any way
is the is is a term and
that's as a fitness right there has to be a
supplement brand for all kinds
of just as ISM's been around for 20 years
so well before I started the edge too
and we have  then
at some point I founded myself
tomorrow so he was a women-
focused brand with a weight loss
focus because I used to be
overweight and then you have to be able to imagine
yourself because you are now
eating extremely fit and broad and the way
you imagine it okay more successful
um
Well, I'll say it in the comparison
to the fitness scene, I'm actually a
leek, no, because the
craziest people are walking around, but for
them, I'm actually more the
type who says hey, I somehow want to do
sports three times a week  and I
want to eat a lot and very much and
somehow I don't want to
look like I like doing it and that's exactly where we
had w  we founded tomorrow five
years ago now five years and after about
two years the founder of ESN approached
us and said hey look here new
time social media we have a
production here are good on social
media you are good at developing products
who are somehow super
We did it at the
very beginning,
because Stefan we can
do a
podcast and have only recently
started to
create structures together  company is um but tell me
Chris you founded the thing at some point
in 2015
so five years ago what is 17 then
probably
how old were you then um so good question
2017 from 23 or something like that 23 yes I can
by chance on social media so me
like most
people probably say somehow that makes social
media successful, that you
stumbled on it by accident  pert is I used to
do professional gaming, so
we were always boring at school
and other people
somehow used it productively to do some
sport or I could have
done Adita in Chinese and
Russian somehow, I
didn't do everything I did  gambled and
then became a professional gamer but won the
Counter-Strike German Championships
and something like that but if you
sit at the PC 14 hours a day and
then like to do it sometimes you've always been
such an emotional eater was in for a
long time so I'll be in at some point
I slipped into an eating disorder like
that, so if you eat almost uncontrolled
amounts of food and
uh, this combination looked like this
at some point and I then decided
about fitness Facebook groups back then
, Facebook groups were still big, I
'm so into  got into this UK research area
, people who are now writing
papers for international
St  They write, they were just in there
in this little circle
because back then evidence was still uncool,
so back then there were bodybuilders who
said hey, I do it and I
've always done it and that's why
this logic works and then there was it
so this small group of people who
say hey anecdotes are important but
maybe we also look at what the
data situation says somehow and that
was relatively uncool at the time nowadays it's
coming Knowle that they say hey we're
trying
to work with scientific data somehow and
then I'm over
I always looked for my social status on Facebook groups, so I
helped people as an
admin, so I
looked around for this social status on Facebook
and then I wrote
a summary for a Facebook group
because there was a
Youtuber there who turned out to be
Supposed to be a doctor but wasn't a doctor at all and
made statements that just weren't
true ha  I wrote something together for the
Facebook group
that that's just not
true and why and a study
and then because I was asked to make a
film in such a really
bad Movie Maker film, I
really put a PowerPoint presentation
with a voice over it  and I mean
it was actually already out in 2017
but the thing somehow
went viral then after a
week had 10,000 subscribers on YouTube what
so I never thought
it would happen like that and then
I knew okay here you can do something and
half a year later we
founded tomorrow
and then from then on then professional gaming no I
am I am so when my my parents was
for my parents gaming was always
so you said hey as long as the
rest works you can do whatever you
want and uh there  First of all, I'm studying
pharmacy and I noticed that
's nothing, um, after
half a year I'm going to study medicine,
after one  Time also determined okay
that's not really fun for me either,
I'm kind of
registering on the side so I can gamble well
Business administration in Mannheim I did that for
five semesters and then stopped for
tomorrow before the bachelor thesis
but that means you've already
somehow  in the summer it's
obviously a clever guy because otherwise you could
probably have
done it
so it's not my fault I'm lucky
from my parents just
but not so completely somehow uh
pushed it in there by accident so you
've somehow gotten one so in
others become more global  or a consultant
or something that would have been all
there my my topic was always I
had so I'm lucky enough to have such
a perfect family no
somehow successful father who is
always there for his children but a
mother who takes great care no
really this this absolute picture
what you somehow have I'm lucky
to have that and I
could never motivate myself to go
the way my father went, so this
my father was with mckinsee for many
years and that's really like
120 hours think for something that
you don't really feel like doing  in order to achieve this
social advancement from the
working-class family, he did
it and um I wouldn't
have managed it anymore, no, I
tried everything in the chips at
investment banks and so on and that
destroyed me emotionally, so that's why I did
it  at some point everything was always done half a year
and tomorrow was just a vehicle
where I suddenly had fun with it and
can work 14 hours back
then what did you
find out first we started with
a more typical quasi
dietary supplement Omega 3 vitamin
D3 and vitamin K2 combined in  a
product that has been the most basic
lever so a vitamin D white
and powder or  r
a mini capsule so to speak, even
then it happened to be
perfect for women when women
somehow didn’t feel like
taking such suppositories and um that was the first product
because it’s like that
when you look at the
food supplement area
and say hey what about one with
a biggest  Probability that it will have
an effect on people, then
this combination is such a very
simple thing, it used to be
discussed a little more often nowadays
, actually everyone knows that vitamin D in
Germany is not that crazy
and that was the first product
we learned about it  and were
always sold out months in advance, so that was it,
everything worked on my YouTube channel back then
and a friend who was the
first influencer is called
leer and then we were always
sold out for months and then we
slowly scaled up and then we got together
at some point in this area purely
developed products to make  en that
allow you to save on sugar or that you
save on taste so that's
actually our thing
these days this field of science is
actually not the the the
how do you say that the the
sexiest but if you have some awesome pictures
of food and videos  and so and
posting that on the social media account that
's super sexy and if you somehow
talk about the fact that a vitamin D deficiency is
not good for your health,
that's not the
sexy first topic, but that's the
passion that we actually come from
So basically there are nutrient analyzes to
understand what do nutrients do in the
body and so on and that of
course also helps us enormously in the
development of the other products but you
are now also from the
groups from Facebook groups and
from the Youtube style he from the
The food or weight loss field does
n't come from bodybuilding or if you
give but that's not actually
the Gru  And why are you doing it, but
rather you come from this world, which has just been
described, where you are in
Facebook groups where it is about losing weight and
somehow, above all, what did
you understand that this should be a
business or what did you see immediately,
man  I've now got 10,000
followers on his paper, do I do
a business or what was it like
back then, it was so that you just
kind of thought, hey, I want to do it
differently than other
brands, so there was a product in
the fitness scene at the time that  BCAAs were called 19, so to speak
, 4 amino acids and everyone just
said hey, that's kind of super
good and that's the luxury supplement
that gives you the last 5%, in the
end it's less effective than
a perfectly normal protein or low-fat quark, well
, it's just that  in terms
of the classification and all
brands offered it, everyone did
it and that was the reason for me
to say okay, I can currently for
I don't really do any brand advertising because I can't stand behind this
product, so I
've always had the view that if
you use a brand as influenza for a product
, you're
positioning the whole brand, because
somehow I think it's just to say  only
one good difficult and um that's why
I wrote to my co-founder at the time
said hey hey I
would like to make a brand that is purely
evidence with a relatively small
product range and just such
products don't make no fat burners
no testosterone boosters but
they all sold that  all completely
pointless products written means
you could actually be
noticed because he had that was
one of the first fitness Youtuber
had 60 70,000 subscribers back then his name is Mick
Weigel and he also helped shape me
a bit as a
viewer because he was always like that
the first to go in was evanes
space too  said I somehow do
laboratory analyzes of products I'll tell
you why Omega 3 makes sense he did
price comparisons so everything was always
away from his person and
never said anything with factual arguments hey I
know that because I do
bodybuilding somehow and that's why it's right
and I have it  I actually wrote to him
and that was my
co-founder and then we
did it in Heilbronn
I was actually doing a
semester abroad in Asia when we
started it just fresh to Asia
that's why I did
n't have any shares at the beginning but my parents
had them because  I wasn't there
and we didn't know what would become of the
project, no, I was, we produced 2000
cans at the beginning, so
made it today
for comparison, eh, he had good
contact with a contract manufacturer at the time and
because he had his own
brand before  built up and um that's
why he took care of it at the beginning I
have  e then contact was established relatively quickly
with the contract manufacturer and
then we have our own production
now and that's exactly how it
came together, okay, always, your
parents were fifty and he was 50
%, exactly there were 2000 cans and
that was them back then  also
surprisingly
gone within three days what she also
thought 0 but then sells through your
youtube channels yes so mainly
through mine so just with somehow
20,000 subscribers or something like that the
channel was
me then Christian Wolf so
yeah exactly so I don't do
youtube today  more but rather
tiktok instagram and stuff like that is just more
fun but that was exactly that
it was the beginning and today we mood
for example on sunday and probiotic
there we somehow have almost 80,000
cans and it will be sold out with a very
high probability
within
our body has different microbiomes almost everywhere,
i.e. on the
skin  there are microbial accumulations of bacteria, so to speak,
and in recent
years more and more research has come
out that above all our
intestinal microbiome had many many different
influencing factors that can have
quite an effect on the psyche, so
it's not just just how
great your bowel movements are  Or do you have a
bloated stomach, but the
bacterial cultures
also play a decisive role in what happens to
our food and, um,
antibiotics are no
longer
prescribed that often, I say well,
that's one of the reasons why
many people do it  For example,
they have problems after taking antibiotics because antibiotics
kill everything, they
are not really important
medicines and can save our lives
at the same time they also have this
undesirable side effect and there
are many before all  Things women
then somehow with on
fight a bloated stomach or
don’t find your sausage that great, basically yes,
it is always difficult to talk about the topic in
some way but you have to
talk about it and
now we have worked with one of the top researchers
for this overhand is called
a probiotics basic researcher  who has been
researching for 30 years
have made a product with
seven clinically studied
clinical studies on the
individual strains, for example
women's health healthy health also
vaginal guide and have made the quasi-
combined safety data
Development has now lasted almost two years
and this effort is worth it
almost none in that area no because a
lot of
what it costs
we will probably make it
or not only probably but
we will make it that we offer 45 € per
can such a short market comparison
a a product that Arthur describes as
bad I can also
like  explain  n why but it is quasi
influenza product costs 80 euros in comparison
if you want omnibiotic so rather
a good product that we try
to recreate you would have to spend at least 193
euros yesterday calculated such a
price comparison in my story
just to get the
same amount of  to get cultures
and we manage to do it now for 45
euros because
simply because we don't have the
structure like a pharmacy, we can
invest a lot more in the product
and still have a good
company in the end because we have our own
Production, own logistics, own
marketing, so we hardly
rely on external influenza in any way,
we have a group of
friends who do it and are also looking for
new people and uh, then we can just
do something like that and say okay, let's
go to the market now  purely that
grows well for me, awesome product and prices
make it very competitive, so
60,000 units  ten will also be
sold immediately, yes, eight, so 80,
probably
€80, that's already a few million
euros in sales, yes, and okay, and that will
continue through your group, not through
other
foreign influenza, essentially through
your team of people through your
accounts  more or less we
have we hardly have any kind of
distanced cooperation
at all when I think about it, well, no,
because we always came
from different areas, so
this influenza never attracted me, these
are these billboards, I say now,
because I  that never found authentic
and I was I was always attracted to people
who were experts in some area
who made it super authentic also showed what
mistakes they have no so if
anyone asks me why are you going
on vacation by plane because I
I'm not perfect and I don't
pretend to be perfect and I thought that was
beautiful  o always much more likeable and
then a group
of friends just developed and
then other people came to us and became
friends I celebrate my self
incredibly he does advertising for
tomorrow because he himself lost weight in the
products and have it
I actually got to know him through the products
and I know I've
often been at his house super nice
person and yes it's more of
a community
what did you get from the whole thing for the first time
a day after I got serious at Westwing
that I  then yes, then
CBC, which I knew from my forward-looking
time, is an investor who is now
with us, is already the best-known
largest products in the world, yes,
definitely in Europe, I think the
best and I knew them and they
got in touch with me  said okay
now you're free do you want to
watch it and did I actually
say no I've done 11 years
because of it  I'm actually
knocked out and now I'm actually resting for half a
year but then I
said okay I
met the guys Chris and
Benny and if you don't
talk do it again and then I looked at
the production
looked at the warehouse and what was it
really cool can we talk about it again in a moment
why the company is so exciting
now from a business perspective too
short form is simply the guys are
totally authentic entrepreneurs who are
extreme technical experts who
develop products that are really better in
the  in a market that is growing
blatantly because this evidence-based
nutrition and and and, so to speak,
nutrition and supplementation is a
huge trend and that in the
business model the company to see with
influencers is blatantly cool
but so and that’s why I’m coming in then
yes well  if it's going so well but it's
relatively unstructured, yes, the
company is still for for  the size is
simply amazingly larger than
2150 million in terms of sales so if
you founded two dogs five six years ago
now 25 just so is not
just the part that I
founded on this this isn part that is
mainly managed by Benny
so  we he basically takes care of it
finally I'll take care of it tomorrow
maybe in the background benni is also
a fitness youtube veteran if he has
me castle smart games underneath
most people probably know
a youtuber i grew
up with in
the end always youtuber you  you saw
made your business partner
yes we the whole thing just always
worked because we found the coolest
people from everywhere
and actually whenever we
meet someone where we say
okay it's fun to work with is a
cool person who has something
special  we're trying to get our
network in for you, that's why it
is  so so so broadened relatively
quickly and erm exactly benny came in the
morning so he left
another company tomorrow
to my company, so to speak, then we realized
that he is so good that we would like to
involve him, so we were always
relatively open  also to say hey the
cake is growing if that helps why
not then he was involved in a morb
and when we did the
merger and built the
structures together he said to him hey
my heart actually beats for
bodybuilding and more has stopped
more and more developed into women slimming
brand because i'm also just
not a bodybuilder maybe a bit
but it's really in comparison to
find scene i'm kinda rag
and then he took care of
esnan took over the place and now he's leading
it make change  there mainly
team the product development structures
I just do the same with the moor and
then we have them gem  lonely
background structure that Stefan leads
who takes care of all other areas
and then there is also a
third person or from the screw
at the beginning who after 20 years only
sold you to this
production manufacturing company
who does not sell so we
actually just made a merger
That was very interesting, so I
'm just not going to say his name now because
I know, but I want to, but
because he's always stayed in the
background, but he has Turkish roots
and at the time he had it ends out of the
forum and actually has exactly that
made the same as we do nowadays
just in the other media forum means
from one who somehow has such a forum
so is exactly active on the internet
and was also in
bodybuilding himself and then said hey for
this forum well I would like to make some
cheap protein powder anyway
in one  high quality and was
so smart from the start that he said
hey m  ow I produce
it myself because then I can undercut all the others then it got
its own so it
only started to produce in the bakery and
then
built up its own production from it so we’re now talking about a
period of 20 years so I
do it in fast forward
and as  the first time we two did Moor for two and a half years he
came up
to us to see how big you guys are getting in
the scene I I don't understand to this
day how he checked that because we
were completely under the radar so
nowadays we call our numbers
and stuff  more because I think it's
more pleasant just to be up there and
look at the order we have it we'll
do it our thing um back
then we were very reserved
and nobody really noticed how
we're growing we'll be
doubling every year  Nobody actually
noticed that, but somehow he had it
on his screen and
I noticed that he was someone who
I would have liked to have had strong partners in his time who would
go on the journey with him
and if something
went wrong say hey, how can we do it
together and then he
invited us to his place and for us it
was such a real moment  because when
it finally invites a company that is x times
as big as you, the German
supplement company, then we are relatively
humble there and then he let it be known in the
conversation that he
is looking for someone who will help him in the future
the company  and
that didn't say that directly either, but
we were so surprised at this formulation,
can he mean that
, really meant we should come
together or something that was totally real for us
and um, yes, a year and a
half later we just noticed
how  a lot are that would result because we
were always sold out even
more blatantly than nowadays therefore
still very often but really like 30
seconds website breaks z  together then
sold out
else a very old shop system
like a one-man booth from Berlin and then switched
to shopify and exactly and
then that was just the point if
okay if we suddenly have access to
our own production with
our own product development we can of
course do a lot  do more we can
develop much better products and
at the same time we can also
take care of the ESN team,
so to speak, that's why Benny
went over and said okay, I'll take care of
the end part, then it
's today's team  four people, so
to speak, Benny the former
Youtube Fitness Influenza du Stefan and
the colleague with Turkish roots
so he's still on board they're
all still on board just now so
clearly different parts but you
know she's doing okay
that has to  Of course
the bakery is also part
of it, so operationally it
doesn't make much difference  he was always
like that he always expressed this wish
that he would like some peace
and quiet and has a family has small children
so maybe it makes
sense to take care of them too and
he never really dared and
what he is his baby too and with the
CVC deal that was the time
when we said okay now I
have to withdraw a little bit
and then he also thanked me recently
that we did that that
he is doing this now too  Can focus on the
family Both co-founders are
still at the start but with much
smaller shares and she has secured them
okay that means somehow now the
capital is like that Chris CBC um the
two
Fitness Influenza Youtube are
ne exactly so benny is him  other
fitness influenza basically erm exactly and
erm Stefan probably also a
bit no erm and okay erm but the
company is now we're talking now yes
if you follow up  look at 250 million
total sales last year and then
you have to pay or you also give out
that you make about 300,000 or that a
month with an average
shopping cart I assume 100 € or
something that's a little less 100
then that's the 30 million a month
there will already be growth to
I don't know 300 50 63 million in
sales this year,
maybe I'll say we don't say any numbers up
front, so to speak, yes, it has to be
finalized first, but we
continue to grow super strong, so we'll be
well over 300 million this year
and want to continue to grow so that's
also the reason why we're building
structures now and why she's invested up to
here that's
because of the structure Hommage
that's not that you're
talking about something in the trading business
with 3% er  but
a bit too high but what's really
cool is that we, well, we make
it to one in the end  n to get
an average good profit
but to have a positioning
that is quite different so that’s why
we’re growing so quickly because we
just manage it ne is also here so
both with Mo and with isn with isn
is probably the best example of
the ISO Klier that  is a clear protein
well you can mix it in a shaker
it doesn't get milky
like the designer way but just like
an ice tea you have 50 grams of
protein in a shaker and
it ends up being by far the most popular
product well  here and there they sell 800,000
cans a month we
even use the esn raw material also because it is so
good and they are still 15 euros
below any market-competent and that's
just this special when you have the
influenza thing
in-house the production in-house the
product development  in-house that we can just
say okay we praise among
other things create but still make the
average good profit and can
Because of this, it grows a lot,
so somehow 20% is still too
high. First of all, I would have thought that it
should work
and uh, you see
, let's just assume a little bit of
head once with 300 million, there would still be 60
million results  feasible
or in the future if you then I
don’t know Halle have sales then you will
probably
be able to do it in the future we definitely want
100 million results have to be in there at the
moment the phase is not that
exciting so no because raw material prices
I think everyone noticed  last
year and a half so it's completely
absurd what happened really
completely absolutely
Christian
if you now listen to it
and
know it from other food brands I don't know
about guest recently or even
ankerkraut or something like that happened the film
food  space
then it is certainly a
very, very clear unicorn what we have in front of
us  Answer Stefan
I think I bought it at the end of the day and
there was an evaluation and it
might be published at some point
but that's not
our job to publish it now I
think and I know it's
exciting whether it's a unicorn or not
that it's not a unicorn
that always depends on it I've
seen it myself at other companies
yes how how was exactly so reviews
are simply volatile
we don't focus on that and really not yes so in
the end of course
we have to invest the company at some point
lead to an exit so there will
either be an IPO or a
sale or a partnership with
someone you have to look at everything that
we are building now is from this company that
somehow has a turnover of over 300 million is
profitable but above all
has a hand  from the really really good potential of the crazy
market in the crazy products team
and
all that  now so far only sales in
Germany no we're only talking
Germany there isn't my
international business yet or something like
that to create structures from it now
so that if
we have a good foundation, let's say
I'm responsible for all the
boring basics  create which of course I
don't find boring at all
but very exciting but
let's say that for the customer and that was
also at Westring so that I
actually
try to build structures, so to speak,
and to build without a company and then
our creative genius, so to speak,
is the work  that you can do
best, namely to be able to
develop products that are super awesome at good
prices and then to be able to
sell them in the blatantly good marketing model, but then
to expand products, so to speak, so even
more products probiotics it's one thing
but there's still one  a lot of what
we want to do new in the two brands  e
target groups yes,
in the end there is one that means the
bodybuilders or performance athletes
gym target group and then you have women
who want to lose weight there are
many other target groups who
want to join and then of course also want
to grow in Europe because the brand, as
I said  so far or both are actually only active in
Germany
now when you came when are you
actually standing a few months ago
16 August and he was at the beginning of the
year no please it will be yes it is
always such a long process so
signing and  closing ne also signing was
so my closing was then I think in
August and exactly but right
now for the first time ever you want
an office somewhere so exactly
so the production of ESN
and there were just some office space
in it but exactly
two meeting rooms and  like 30 40 desktop
or so and otherwise just
production so we've always been
both companies were vo  The focus has always been on the
product, so the product has always been
accurate and the rest was
always okay. We were
set up remotely, which is why we were
super lucky during the Corona period because
practically nothing changed for us,
then luckily we were allowed to continue
producing food  were always
allowed to continue producing were
set up remotely from the start were exactly
in the space people were
interested in becoming a student and I
'm at home all the time and cook
more and eat more but
maybe I don't want to weigh 15 kilos somehow
increase is actually exactly the
right space for it
and there is such a thing or there is a
big thing the tent above all
for moors where mankind simply has
not yet understood or most
people have not yet understood how
easy it actually is  so
why did he put it really well
the other day he kind of had a
roundabout 10 with us  Lost kilos and
then made a YouTube video where he
said he
was just annoyed that he had
n't checked earlier how easy it can
actually be but I
also remember myself earlier I
kind of tried to
lose weight because I had a huge one  pain i
never had a girlfriend and somehow just wanted to
look better and feel better
my body yes i was
until 18 19 i don't have a girlfriend and
i i don't have this this
connection how it works from
nutrition and so everyone knows that
when  more is that you
probably gain more weight but well then
you somehow try
to make an apple and then you somehow
don’t read KABS after 6 p.m. and then you read
this again and then you read that again
and how easy it is at the end  actually
really is ne that just says hey
in most of the food we
eat nowadays there is quite a lot of
added sugar ne di  find a person in the
supermarket if you just
do the easy yourself and replace it
you've already had several hundred
calories a day so you'll get your protein up a
little doing 10,000 steps a
day is a little bit of fruit and vegetables and
you train twice a week
so if  you want to look good
without a lot of lifestyle effort let it
do things and you will
look better than average and
that's something that is our job
to communicate via social media and
that works so well
that you can open it in the remote
structure during the corona period, so to speak  once
without an office actually had a company
that was then yes before the deal
you then probably already made over
100 ne logically yes so yes
should actually be okay that means
a lot of people see it that way too
hit where just now
since such a new window is opening where
at that time supplements were
looked at anew  n can you say it like that
yes there is, at least i know
nobody is always stupid to say something like that
or it always sounds a bit stupid but
i don't know anyone who is as fanatical
about products as we are so there are
still so you do
research anyway but  with you, you are
also making your Instagram account public
quite a headwind, so there is
this Quarks editorial team here from the ARD,
I think they should be a bit
crossed over with them, regularly questioning
whether what you are doing there really is what you
have to criticize  yes
that the exciting thing is there are
people who somehow say something like yes
the state media are controlled no
I think this direction is
nonsense what is but of course there is
that I
set narratives in certain organizations so that kind of
one above all very much
government organizations are very common
in these narratives of
dietary supplements being
so expensive  No, this thing and if something like that is available in the
organization, then of
course there are often attempts to report in this direction.
At the
same time, the
food supplement sector in
Germany is in a problem, which
is understandable, however, a small example
if you go to the doctor and then
you have vitamin D  deficiency ne blood value
shows you have a vitamin D deficiency you
ask me as a supplement manufacturer hey
what should I take the logical answer
I am not allowed to say exactly as a supplement manufacturer
because a vitamin D deficiency
is a disease
food supplements must not be
recommended for diseases although
it is obviously in  will help in this
case because I mean what else is
vitamin D supposed to help but it's
forbidden to talk about it and it's
understandable where this rule comes from no
because you told him okay you should
n't apply a vitamin C against cancer
and the logic is different  understandable
that you shouldn't do that
but te also has problems that there are
many food supplements that
are obviously effective, such
as vitamin D in the case of a
vitamin D deficiency but you shouldn’t
talk about it and then the media
uses this narrative of
food supplements cannot
or cannot help diseases
Helping diseases that's practically
wrong you're not allowed to communicate when
food supplements help with illnesses
so yes of course I ca
n't take vitamin C for cancer now
the chatter there are many the
rules make sense but she also comes
with problems and that's just the way it is
a topic where you say okay we are
enthusiasts we know how much
you can achieve with it and how
important these spaces are and then you
have some organizations that come from
a different era that
see the whole thing a bit differently and
then you have
brilliant scientist for this discourse  or something like that
there aren't any so one would
assume that it's also very
profound so there are both so there
are good and there are
bad posts with Quarks what I looked at that
yes it is then of course I also
looked at yes  and the
controversies that exist there are also
exciting, I actually compare it
with every technology, yes, if
technologies start earlier in
eCommerce, that means the same thing,
the laws are simply not there at the time,
you can whether in OBD out
topics of data protection, yes  so
we can do that now in a completely equivalent way,
there is simply the regulation and
the state of knowledge in a
situation that you
actually have in the market and that
also and I know now change
and our market is also evidence-based and
from  can already be shown by scientists
there is simply that of the
license just a few years
later so and and and there you have it
Conflicts yes and now we are
sweeteners is just an example
that has with me I have been
drinking diet coke for 30 years yes and and other
drinks here
Red Bull exactly like that and what I have had for
30 years when I drink and I
drink  no alcohol e.g. mine tastes
good anyway and then people who
drink alcohol in front of me always tell me
you know that you have to be careful
with the sweet no yes and so and
that's why [ __ ] yes there are now
really proven studies
study situation very clearly the sweater
just
Of course there are also sweeteners that
aren’t that great, no, they are no longer the ones that are used
nowadays, no
, the technology is
evolving and aspartame is
such a good example that I also
like to talk about because we do
n’t use any products  but not
because it is somehow harmful, but
because the representation in the media is like that,
but if you look at it tr  ansplatan
simply consists of two amino acids
finylalanine aspirinic acid which are found,
for example, in avocado, in
chicken meat and so on, so
when you consume aspartame, which has happened to you
in your body, it separates
into these 2 amino acids, which creates
a little methanol, that's how
people sometimes get it  are a little scared
but less than with tomato juice and
that's it then these two
amino acids are metabolized
and at the end when you understand that you can
no longer be afraid of aspart but
if you read articles in the media
and no, they have
aspart  anything else you're afraid of and that
's our job and also the reason
or one of the reasons why we've
grown pretty quickly because we just
collect this background information
, for example we have a lot of
people from the Facebook groups back then,
one of them is called Alex, for example  ran at
the time as the primal kit of this
Facebook group  active he
later became the researcher from
exament.com one of the largest
supplement analysis websites which is
also described as good by Quark, for example,
um, and we then recruited him
into our research team, so to speak
, he now writes studies for white n,
i.e. for  international journal and they
prepare a lot, which
we then implement in communication and in the
products,
much more than an influencer brand
where someone is now using their reach
to say I can turn a normal
product into a cool brand,
but you really are  very
product-oriented you now out and
deep into that also what I
think is such a pity when I see what
influenza sometimes
do for cooperation where you stop this iced tea example
ne I find this whole ice scene but
also funny but we
really need the 18 sugar  You couldn't have made iced tea
somehow cool,
okay maybe a little Nä
making the whole topic sugar-free
and somehow also
talking a little bit about the fact that maybe
children shouldn’t drink 40 grams of sugar in an
iced tea can
so influenza actually have the chance
to make something much cooler than the
market well because they don’t have to  Money for
marketing numbers with your own brand, well,
you can go from 0 to 100
within a very short time, you
can do market tests with your community
, and then that's often
used to somehow, as you say, make
standard products a little more expensive to
travel and then somehow  Selling fake airports
on Instagram and I
think what
is different in all brands of the quality group is this
unconditional initial product focus,
so we have to make a product that is
better. I found a saying
that Chris used earlier, so I can
still use the brand  not change standing
street this is i believe that this
we want ei  n develop a good product
okay then of course we still have to start a
business we have to produce ourselves that
has to take good measures and then it has to
work but it always starts with
a good product and then
communication is important because, for
example, sweeteners are then real
a good example and with protein and
so on that that's very similar of
course a sweetener so
ideally we'd all have
some kind of broccoli that's
steamed with no oil on it with a little
salt and maybe like that and the
fish you want three times a day  a
bit of quinoa great yes like Tom Brady
diet something like yes
unfortunately that's just unrealistic so
now if you can't if you
can't then the question is what
do you do not what is the next
step and then everyone says yes okay
sweeteners are  not good because you
can already show something in the body that they
are not good in comparison
to a brok  koli but if I
eat sugar instead, then the
sweetener is definitely much
better because it has no calories and
a few small effects happen in the body
like the methanol and so on,
but that's just a lot less than
if you eat sugar  and
then there is the
realism that is sometimes missing in the industry
or where we just say okay,
people just want to eat sweets now
let's stop them from having to
eat sugar that they put stuff in it
let protein powder yes the perfect
protein powder might not taste good
then you put sweetener in it
and that's somehow
enriching it with good things so that it becomes even more
valuable simply
making products that simply feed the people of
now better and that's what
it starts with and that's the cool
thing about the company  really i
think we make the world a
better place by having really better
products than others i  n the industry
and if people take more of our
products, which hopefully will also be
healthier, you would think that
there are other food companies
that would already be doing the same thing,
so this gap now exists
today, I would never have thought that
you would see it  Yes, more and more protein
products too, it's not as if that's
as if we're the only ones who
checked it and separates it, we were only
comparatively early there, we
dared to communicate it and
just built up the development capacity to
do better in this area
develop than others but
five or seven years ago if I
remember back then there was
so when you said the word protein
people tended to say be
careful that it doesn't take that much
or no so
kind of kidneys and stuff and nowadays
white  yes everyone actually the protein is a
positive adjective there is of course
also nonsense like somehow P  red
gummy bear well but if you are now a
supermarket then you buy pudding
and one has somehow three grams of
protein 40 sugar and the other is
sugar-free and has 40 grams of protein that is
the better choice and that
understands nowadays or more and more
people understand  it's clear that
the market is improving okay now
you have how many brands in the
portfolio
we added got7, for example,
or that was right there I knew the
founders and I always thought they were
super cool product developers,
so they're really in
really tight in this snack area and
their company was actually a
by-product of this
product development, but they were never
able to structure it properly,
similar to ours, only on a much
smaller scale and we
then brought them in and have their product
expertise in this suffering food  -Area
in the more expanded so we have, for
example, the hal with barbecue sauce  t
instead of 160 calories, eight calories per 100
milliliters, so okay, that all
adds up very quickly, so if you
look at it individually, it’s always like 50, 100, 150
calories, okay, but if you have that
three times, no, and then
you suddenly end up with 400, 500  Calories a
day less then it changes,
that means there is still a brand like
Vaio, there is still a sub-brand
of ESN for performance athletes, then
there is an own brand called Synergy,
these are energy drinks,
then there is another brand that
we  don't talk yet and
what's the best and then there's fit man
our brand where you can buy practical fitmart.de
where you can buy products from all brands
and what so what
people buy the most there's kind of
so at at isn that you have it
Protein burns in Germany so if
you go to the gym you see above
all there is a first without when
someone asks which protein is used so it
is likely  The answer is n
there is quasi design away that is the
milky protein and there is the isolating
that is this juice protein which has brought something
new
to the market at all the category didn't really exist before that
and at Mohr it's
Junker  this is the flavor powder that
you can put in anywhere that also
shows why all the time that means
you just take it like Stefan says
in the optimal world we just take
a ski from the shelf
somehow put three blueberries in it or
100 grams of food that  and colleagues like
that I find absolutely un sexy I was able to do that for
a few months then I got
into the eating disorder and that
allows these products that
a ski suddenly tastes like
cherry yoghurt yoghurt or vanilla
flavored powder which is the largest
part inulin  a dietary fiber then
pieces of fruit suites so sokalosis
stevia
such a small can where that just
a liquid there  nn on top there are
pieces of fruit that's cool
or a crunch like that, the inulin
is also included, so as roughage,
the consistency is better and I mean
roughage isn't the
worst idea either, um, exactly, and
you can have that in everywhere from
coffee to baking  that the protein and
then, um, so to speak
, the flavor powder has been around for a
long time, well, I used
one when I was at school
, but they were all so tasty
that for a few weeks you didn’t
feel like it anymore and that was that  the big
change with the chunky clever we managed to
taste that it tastes like
products you already know i
don't want to name it the brand but
if you go to the supermarket shelf and
you get a yoghurt that many
children from our childhood there are two or
three brands  we just managed
that it tastes in this direction that
you are really reminded of
the z  Sugar products that you used to eat
but that has without
many people working for you currently
more than 300 that means and with you it
was all quite fresh through my scene
the takeover that means you
already have the company up to 250 or or your
own acquisition  done that
everything was decentralized when I was 28 that's quite
unusual because your father had a
bit I was super lucky with
my environment well my father I have
no idea about taxes I have no
idea about finances that did
everything I haven't even  Online
banking access because I'm really,
I actually only do products and
social media because
I enjoy those areas and I'm completely
useless in everything else and my
father always dealt
with these topics, so
I brought in CBC in the finance company structure, so he has he has that
I always did this main work in the background, how did the BBC come about, so did the euc  h
or were you looking for an
investor and then he could
or my father originally
even said before the esn deal or I think
before the esm deal hey
let's go to court because
there are important questions
so if you say okay
we need backup somehow and
we want to do this exercise to
say hey what should a company look like
so that it is more stable because that's what it's all about
in a process like this
nobody wants to go in anywhere because it falls down in the
back then has  You took
care of the structures in the
contracts and so on and
then we stopped the process again at the
time but said we did
n’t want to bring anyone in, so we did
it with ESM and then
we said okay, let’s do this
exercise again  we didn't really know at the time
what the goal was
, we all got to know each other
somehow from Karla  the whole thing
, I think, apart from Blackrock,
we actually all got to know it was a
totally surreal experience, so
you could talk to Easy because your father
knew her, no, it went through you through
an MMA consultant and they then did
a bit of coffee meetings and
they were so totally awesome  Experience also
getting to know all that and
CVC then came in and we had the
first meeting and Benny and I
sat in the car afterwards and said if they made us
an offer they said yes immediately
because they were
you really saw that they met us for
the first time  and
asked the right questions the second
time, they understood 80% of our company
, and with the third
man they made suggestions for us on
what we could improve, but not in the
sense of hey back, maybe a
machine here a meter further to the
left  then you can efficiently save 0.5%
but you would
have looked at how the
overlaps are  ung among your team
members and have you ever
seen that really cool thing yes, and
then she made us an offer
, which we were very
happy to accept,
but you don’t do a capital increase, so to speak,
you do a real one that you sell
and  his shares depends on who
so we have more shares now than
before so if you didn't
both or both took out more shares than
before or so they
actually paid us so that was
a very nice thing for us because they
said  hey, you
somehow deserved to be a bit
secured, they did
that and that was nice too, but the
cool thing was we had, so I
also dealt with it before that, okay, how
does the time look like afterwards and it was
really okay that happened  and
then really good people came, so she
introduced us to Stefan, we
also saw other candidates that
we met  fen noticed Stefan right
away okay we want him
then Stefan came along then I had a
um she until she gave me a um at
President of Uli
Lieferservice was
pretty good at Unilever he met
him in London also said
okay we need him
to convince the business and so
suddenly really good people came in who
help us to actually fix these structures
that we need so benny
and I concentrate fully on productive
if you think about it if you even before
the deal he probably had through them
Dividends Dividends or the
results of the first few years of success
were probably a little bit
left, yes, I had it for me
anyway. I am always happy in that aspect.
I am also very open about it. I have
a very successful father
never had the motivation
to say hey i
'm basically sacrificing my whole life to
be somehow  i to become a Goldman Sachs
analyst and to work 120 hours
I could never do that he did I
couldn't do that and that's why I was
always lucky that well I'm for
the now fortunately my own
money I knew but okay no matter what
happens for  my own money
I can't I can't
complain so it definitely wasn't
at the same time it wasn't
so I so I haven't had a phase
behind me where I suddenly
somehow bought bottles in Munich in the P1 club
so
tell me how  was because you did it
like that as a hobby
in Facebook
groups and then you started
to order your first own cans
somehow and at some point you
always told your father that I'm selling
here now for a few million
products  now again or
did he follow it a bit from the beginning
, so I even went with him
to my co-founder because I
s  I thought it would be weird when
a 23-year-old guy
shows up and says he wants a company with
the reasons because the fitness scene is
n't known for that
either  communicated to Regensburg
and then we met and yes
then I also said hey
I have it with me so you know here
is also a serious site, so to speak not
only 20-year-olds
want to do something but also someone with a
bit of experience  and he was there from the
beginning you are now on
Instagram the biggest account is uh no
bigger how much do you have there 420 or something like
that so these are big numbers but
now Instagram has 300,000 or
something less yes of course there are
n’t any now either  Huge numbers, that means
where does this market penetration come
from, so if you're in Germany, only
in Germany you make so many sales
then mu  ss you can also reach a whole range
of people only with your
account or with the accounts of your
partners you don't want to go at all
so you're almost too small for that
or no no these are actually
accounts they make up for
example a rezo  well I love such a
brilliant guy and that's so I'm
so proud that he stands for our brand so
much, but he's not the
one who brings in a large part of a
new customer, it's
really
80% of our team are customers who are over
Social media have become a team, for
example Madeleine Nadine Laura, they
are all people who have lost
weight with our products. Mama
Madeleine, for example, is a mother
of I think two children, who has lost around
15 kilos and has
shown Moor and her way for a year and a half
basically shown without getting anything for it
and at some point I discovered you
about story people ne who
somehow had 20,000 subscribers  because exactly
marked she even said hey
ordered with Christian
's code so really really cool because she
doesn't have any of that and then I always
wrote to you what do you think about getting
your own code no and
then she did it and of course it was
from the beginning  to disproportionately
successful because the people who
follow her are only there because they celebrate the path
and they know that they have
really used the products and
that's where the success
comes from if you know that it's really
like that so come to us  I do
n't think anyone would think about the idea, are they
really going to lose weight with the
junkie or do they do something
different
than someone who
goes to the gym for performance reasons, or now we also have
two MMA fighters and the contract they
ultimately come from this one too  Community
then comes, yes, and then they get it in code, so to speak,
and then mostly advertise the products
they use anyway
and with that  Do you have
super authentic marketing, yes, because
the people might already show the mother that
anyway and then you
now have a code for it and
then of course we will support it, we
will then send it the new products and
so on, so of course there is then
we are we get total so the 90% of
our people just have
commission I don't know if you
recognize illegally Elias honestly sold
his own brands
millions of bottles and of his
products
that does
n't matter to him but he
always has ESN himself  bought then wrote to
ESN said even
marked it in the story said yes
finally I want a basket and
then that came up that’s also one of the
typical sentences you hear when people
switch to us this yes I have here
you bought your products,
yes, they are somehow from
another supplement manufacturer or
from another brand, whatever and
then  So this year I bought your products from her
and the plan is
to open up other new areas, so now
besides Jim and bodybuilding and weight loss
focus on women, I have understood
what the next area is that you can
tackle there, so there is  then that's
a huge question in a company like that
no but I think at isn it's currently
football NMA as the first area and
then almost every sport a bit
like Nike no that
you have the most important products in almost every sport
and then yes  many things are the same for
all athletes it is important to
eat protein that sleep well to be
supplied with nutrients that is
after all a tennis player is not
different there are of course
individual differences, for example
with endurance supplements like please
alone which does not make so much
sense in weight training  but that's the
way Mohr spreads the sport, it's much
more likely that we'll reach the broad masses
and show him  en how easy it actually
is so by the ear is actually tomorrow
we want to do events soon, for example
, where we just say hey
we go to a university,
for example and simply give out skis
with Schunki flavors and have to go out,
just say hey here in healthy
snack breaks  just for people to have that
experience to understand okay
it doesn't have to taste bad just because
it's healthy and how easy it can
actually be but for a
college student throwing in flavor slogans
done it's here is this
scandinavian yoghurt-like exactly that
's sort of like a low-fat quarker yr
written so relatively similar to low-
fat quark is only more constant in
quality, so it can normally be the case that
sometimes you have a super creamy one or
somehow one that has a nice
structure and it's always
relatively similar and what role
it all plays is still everything that
Tussi or meanwhile act ne
is part Ha  ndel so the big
part is the chick so for our
own shops then there's a part that
runs through Amazon and then there's a
part that's also in bricks-and-mortar
retail like Rossmann and
Rewe to be exact and that's one of the things
where more  Structures are needed because
for us, of course, this is at least a more complex
business than the chick, where of course we
also have to make commitments
why the sales team has a brown
structure in the products that
have to become more stable in spirit, so all the
things that you simply
don’t have to consider when dosing them
Of course we don't necessarily want to do it
because it only
brings additional sales, but because if you want to have
a mainstream penetration as a brand
, then you know, at some point you also want to
be positioned everywhere
further instead of only in the
funnel, so to speak, of the influencers  work with
us
and to do that he has to be you
as a brand
so hardly
anyone knows the brands unless they know someone who uses them, the
brands are actually still so unknown,
which was funny in this whole
investment process, somehow, uh
at Kicker, the person responsible said
to me yes, of course, I know the junkies, but a
friend of mine recommended it to me after the
pregnancy, no, and with
all the men, what’s more likely, they
say yes, of course, here in the office, there
are somehow 18, it decides it’s kind of
cool because of that  we also had so we
got absolute special treatment from all the people
because somehow
in CBC with their negotiating experience
they could have turned us left and right
without us having
any chance and that was
super cool right from the start well and that's why
we had it  We also have such cool structures
because they are very
entrepreneurial themselves and because they support us
somehow no when I call him
we need a machine here says yes
okay are you sure I say yes and
then we bought the machine that
is
but one is one of the leads who is basically
responsible for us and
phone what I meet me
again tomorrow with them that's really a
cool relationship you have the entire
value chain, so to speak, the
production is that it stays in the
only standard you can then because in
Elmshorn now, so to speak, to supply such a fast-
growing company permanently from there
or exactly the location is
currently production and logistics and
product development Elmshorn will be a
long-term production site,
which means we are expanding
production by moving the logistics
to Kaltenkirchen, it is also
here near Hamburg,
we have two halls there and they are
being ramped up, then the
logistics will start  out of Elmshorn we're doing
the logistics hall we're building e  a
production hall and
then expand production there and then
product development, which is
currently mostly in a
rage and partly still remote,
we want that in Hamburg, we will
build or set up in the laboratory,
so whatever  we get
that out there, where we can then
take product development
to the next level,
because that's ultimately where the company
comes from and that's why it's
exactly where we
rented in Hamburg two months ago, there are still 10 15
now  Today we are 60 70 or
so, so some of the people who are
remote come together, then some of the
people we are hiring, of course we are
now mainly hiring in
Hamburg and the new executive team, the
people who have now joined see
Hiero Chief  Operating Officer Chief
digital Officer Office I then is
here it has been since the
year everyone is there now  t in the Hamburg
office or CEO or even a
Kaltenkirchen in Elmshorn but that
somehow not only in Hamburg but
also I think in Africa you are a lot
South Africa that's a little bit you
're so difficult to get over the thing, a
little bit over the world  spread out
we were already at Moor has
grown completely remote because we
always found people who
we thought were cool and then we
couldn't force anyone to
say hey is coming to Regensburg
or Munich or something else so by the
ear he is  The main location or the
main logistics location in Regensburg
simply grew organically because mica
used to be there and that’s why we’ve
always been set up remotely and
I actually always lived in Munich
until just before that, I’ve decided now,
okay, I just feel a
lot better in winter when I’m not
in  the cold and darkness I'm so there
are people who don't mind
it gi  bt really people so it
's with me is I need three hours
more sleep in the winter I can't
really film videos but it's
kind of still dark at 3
p.m  go exactly in the winter and otherwise
then again Munich yes Germany
Austria a bit so everything
possible where there is just that the beautiful
light there is for example a
cool gym which I really like and
I have no free time during the day apart from
my lesson Jim die  I'll go and
then we'll just do it because that means
that's right it's really cool there,
so we always roll the dice
together a little bit so that we say okay,
we know we work 14 hours a
day, then we have to structure the rest so
that  we don't
work during the day, yes, it's just
video production, I mean I build
a complete team around me for
my positioning, so to speak, then k  If
we take care of it, it's about explaining to people
how social media works, that's
also one of our skills,
then we do the product development and
then you have to consume a lot
, so to understand social media
you kind of have to go
through the comments everywhere  look
look okay how does
the tiktok algorithm change SEO change well that's
everything has to do everything and I
don't see it as that of course the
typical saying I don't see it
as work but it's just I do
n't know what else to do anyway  should
do but tell me, um, you have Instagram there
just because there aren’t 20 25 posts and the
rest is so you work a lot for
the stories no,
I recently took out all my old
posts because I said okay I
used to  very very rarely posted
because I had
no time to
do anything, especially in this CVC, but that was something that was still on
my P  latte was and I've
only just really started again with my
own videos, so to speak for the
Explorer page, because now I
finally have the time for Stefan and the structures that are coming
again, but
you always have many many stories live
exactly so sorry  I a lot
because it's just a super cool
tool I mean how cool is it that you have something like that
in your pocket on the TV station
and
you can do it very quickly tiktok and so it's always
more effort to leave the videos with
subtitles and stuff like that  next bag
is always relevant just Instagram more
relevant is that right or is that
wrong so for conversion Instagram
is by far the most relevant
still because the story is just a brilliant
feature um thanks for
the connect to Thomas by the way I also asked him
recently  why you
don't actually get asked at tiktokoll Thomas
why you actually do
that through feature at tiktok so schl  really
do it because tiktok does a lot
right but the story feature is just
complete rubbish just because tiktok is
awesome at saying I'll take a
video which is good you have almost no
followers and you get them directly or
you have lots of plans or are doing  but a
bad video and you don't get any
exporters in it are good but
if people have already decided to
say hey they want to see a lot of you
there should actually be a
feature to say okay that
not everything has to be trimmed to reach
and  that's
what Instagram does very well when people
decide that they want to follow
you then you have your story and
if you fill it interestingly
you get constant views, so I
kind of always have 80 90,000
views my fiancee has kind of
200,000 stories  Views and people
are just interested in it and what
is or your you have a special
relationship with Pamela reif h  but I also
observed on Instagram I find her
really likeable so
no Pam is so you can’t
find her unsympathetic either no this super
nice pretty woman who is successful
and that also makes everything good I come
from a different direction I come
from the  Direction to say okay what's
wrong so how likeable
someone is I'm definitely not the most
likeable person but what is
right and saying this topic hey
I'm selling coconut blossom sugar as a
healthy alternative doesn't make any sense
you know you then actively criticize I
just criticized the products
because Pam so it started a
year and a half ago, she wrote a
story about her chocolate and
said okay, there are
n't that bad sweeteners in it, but that was
the first point, but you said yes
, maybe you should reconsider that a bit
and then basically  hey there
is no industrial
sugar here either, but coconut blossom sugar  d that sounds
for the line as if that
would be healthier why else should one emphasize
it but industrial sugar is
ultimately only sugar from sugar beet or
from sugar cane because it is also from
a plant both are glucose
fructose molecules and stop
nothing different in the body but that
means you weren't
attacked by her so much now, so you
're more in the
role of enlightening, so to speak, and tell
me, man, it's about the
correct information on the net and and a
little bit if you do that that  Quarks from
Pamela Reifen is exactly what I used to do
and I can honestly
say that I used to make it much more
unsympathetic than today because
I just had a different image of
people, so I assumed
that many people would do something
wrong and you know  that it is wrong
, such a relatively negative image of
man and with what I'll
say now  growing up I
also noticed a bit
that
something like that is totally logical she is a
great person who tries to do good
things she thinks
coconut blossom sugar is healthier because she heard
that somewhere then she just makes it
her own conscious
and then suddenly you're in a
thing like that where she can't get out anymore,
so she's already
answered that or something like that, yes, she sort of
started the last video
because she was asked in the interview by
the interviewer what she was
actually says about the criticism of
coconut blossom sugar and I
think she didn't really
want to say anything about it because the answer was
not good in terms of content, so she was
likeable as always but just
not good in terms of content, I think she
didn't want to say anything about it because it was
kind of stupid  Situation because of the
interviewer and I
just answered that but that does
n't mean personally in Ko  nakt or something,
no, I also have absolutely nothing, so it
doesn't promote you either by not offering you
anything at all, so to speak, that
means not at all okay as
objects of enlightenment without that, yes,
I will, yes, from my family, I
have very close community contacts  No, and
when she positioned her chocolate
and said hey sweeteners are
n't that great and that's why
I don't use it and I got coconut sugar, I
got thousands of messages with
the story and then I
said what I said in my story about it,
hey that's right  not like that and then
I also made a tiktok video out of
it so I guess the
story views like 80 90 000
people somehow okay with these really I can
post 25 stories a day and the
stories are constant so that’s why
I think  I that they are very close together
, what's the rumor about it, that
you might even want to open a doctor's office,
not even that  little even if it is
no longer so
exactly you are legally
not allowed to own a doctor's office as a doctor
so there are companies that can
dribble that so if you have a
lot of money then you buy a
hospital and then you can set up a business
in the VZ  in Germany
there are very big ones, for example the
companies that are behind the dialysis
machines or are behind them sounds so bad but they
simply
produce the analysis devices there is, for example, a
company that buys hospitals and
builds medical centers from them and then
we can do that there  doesn't do that
and honestly doesn't make any sense,
but we've teamed up with a
doctor and we're making an
information service provider for medical practices,
so the idea is the following: in
medical school you get
comparatively little information about nutrition,
so many people think doctors
automatically have an idea of ​​​​nutrition through
medical school, that's it  not so doctor is
no  Nutritionists will
confirm that every doctor who is
good and somehow modern and
at the same time many doctors want that
but you don't stand a chance
in today's medical environment,
you somehow have 24-hour
hospital services and so on, they
know you then  further education
, so first of all you have to have the competence
to be able to read a study
and you didn't
get that in medical school and then you don't have to give
yourself a chance like that and
we're trying to solve this problem we say
hey we already have one  Doctors and
nutritionists who no longer have to use
this time in
practice but can deal with
data put it
together and then offer it to practices
or have the work with
us about this
information and then you as the
end consumer know what to say  hey if you go to
the practice that works with
us then we  I just eat,
for example, that they are familiar with
blood values, that they just
typical example when someone goes to the
doctor and or comes from the doctor and says yes,
my doctor has done a complete blood count
is everything okay,
you've probably heard it somewhere, a
big blood count has nothing to do with it  to do
if it's extensive the full
blood count is about the
blood cells being further split up
but
we're not talking about Norway here no matter
what it's about in medicine or in
biology you're someone who
wants to go deep into it and understand it in detail
da los ist could
also be very good that i
think in one area i could have become a
good doctor i.e. in
this singular focus that i
enjoy no somehow hormones nutrition
soldiers i could have become good i
ultimately don’t even do it
nowadays  much different than someone like
that would do now, even though of course I'm
not a patient i  somehow allowed to
practice or sun
completely understandable what I really enjoy
is building the team who are
much better than me and easy
to work with them that means but about the
medical practices question number two
you answer he will be a service provider and not
medical practices yourself and say
maybe now finally, because I
wanted to ask Stefan here again,
you've
done classic e-commerce for many years now, where you always think like that
in custom acquisition Coast and so and
now all of a sudden you're looking at here
and there  they don't even exist they
are practically zero was so there is an
infrastructure and we also pay
commissions to our influenza so
insofar as there is yes and of course we
have to now and and that's exactly
why I'm here and that's why
she's there for them like her  In the next phase of the
company, many of these, shall we say,
normal e-commerce structures will already be
needed because that's easy now  So
the company that drives very fast
but it also wobbles because there
is a lack of a foundation because there is a lack of
transparency because there is simply a lack of
structure and
we will not take care of it
today but we will
take care of the cost position next year  we will do
a bit of marketing marketing
we will do a
bit more now we will also do
data transparency so yes we have so
you have to say very basics we
don't even have an analysis of first
customers turn reactivate so a very
basics die  somehow a company is
usually a year old
has there not yet our our
financial closing lasts 60 to 90 days
for each month we have a
limited march transparency and so
on and that's all the
negative white totally crass
sold to whom we litscheli
Have made a loss because nobody except because
we have in the product E
We just developed the development and
said okay we put in 35%
pieces of fruit pieces from
wild berries and
then make a high proportion of fruit powder
now costs per can and then it was
noticed in retrospect okay
sort that means we are
simply lucky overall that we
grow through this bad majority of the products
and growth solves many problems
at the same time you have to be
careful at some point
that you somehow  but the transparency
is good that you don't
just the guys just
made the right decision really brilliantly from the gut
that
has already been said they have
a product in which maybe you could be
better but overall the company is
profitable growing has mega  awesome
products and  has everything that you have in the
great company
in the first two years because we worked together with
the wage tax
so what would not have
been possible would have been to order all the products from our own cash flow
at all
but the contract manufacturer with whom we
still have a  had very good contact
who gave us the opportunity to
say hey you can order and you
have a 60 days I think that was the
same way of payment and he
just made it unlimited even beyond his
credit line when I basically
just trusted us  because seen
the company Monster Knaller drive of
course and is there now completely out
so that's the work is still
together with the even though our own finished
at all that may also continue we
have a few products that we ca
n't manufacture ourselves where we then with
extreme  work
together and lots of things
for example we have we have to
be  ispiel packaging what we can't
do so we sometimes have wrong
boxes because simply more
information fits on the label on
a wrong eight logically we don't have a case box system
now,
that means we produce e.g
somehow with the growth and
the environment imagine on the wages
manufacturer or the case box
manufacturer said awesome the boys
are there or that you
have met a niece because then of course they
are now more
adults for many of our partners and
and  we have to
continue to maintain these partnerships, so to speak
, but scale the company in
general, so at the end of the
day we will increase in all areas,
so to speak. Europeanization is
probably one of the biggest
long-term levers, unfortunately already Switzerland
Austria we don't even
focus in any way  siert well we don't have a
Swiss website in francs or anything like that
we might agree with
high fees because we have to pay the numbers no but nobody really bothered
about that but since the day
before yesterday tracking has been on we
now know how many Swiss can be
implemented
[Laughter]
then you get
a part of the shares from CDC so that you can
install
it correctly, so I talked to CBC at the
time, yes, and said okay,
now that they're so clean who's
probably not mine, but ah, such
a cool company and Peter  then the
opportunity to invest yourself
that I find exciting what do you already
have there about any Hamburg there
is a startup I hear
rumors that you might
buy again
sometimes about rumors yes
that means you are also M&A something else is coming
somehow or is the idea
of ​​the deal is to continue
buying that is to be
honest we have it all
Strategy currently but one of the
options that we'll do it at some point
what we're coming up
from the logic right now okay there's the
target group that we might not be
able to do well with the existing brands and
where we believe that we already have it with a
brand  we then have to completely
reposition it because our
products are simply really better,
whether we should do it again with the
airport and that is e.g.
also in the long term, so
nobody can take care of it at the moment, not even
me because we don't have time for it
but  just like the example
spoke Influenza Brands ne so Influenza
are currently going to
some ice tea manufacturers or something
and say hey let's make the next ice
tea yes so how could the brand
be where say hey let's make a
cool sugar-reduced product
with  kinda ne kinda super
mainstream crass influencer and says
hey joint vent  ure whatever it is with
them 20 25 no idea what what
percent no we make sure that
your products are really awesome
and you do that and that's one
thing, for example I see something huge in the
future of this creator economy
is because that's what we can
deliver which person in mind
who doesn't care as a partner
but yes but we can really
become
that so
the thing is I've said that many times before
I think if
we talked we would
n't  hard to understand because I think
she's a nice person and I
'm not a bad person
either the question is always a little bit
and that's really super
difficult
does she get out of this situation a
little bit because I mean because
actually it's total  understandable, she
thinks that it's just healthier and
that's why she has dealt with it
and also thinks naturalness is good, which is
completely free  n is like that and then she
just took this knowledge and
tried to convey it and if
it turns out that's
not really true and you need a whole
brand on it you've got a
bit of
good advice this time and B on Smart  insofar as that
I'm quite sure if you got to
know each other at least you
would like each other and uh then know it says but
it would definitely be very appropriate
that you say she
definitely has the right target group I think
she is also a human being  with so that's the
way it is she has very, very high
demands on herself so no because she
would never go there and
say hey I'm applying now so I'm
applying for something that she doesn't stand for the
question is always true what she
stands for or that is  Yes, another question,
but the idea of ​​values ​​is
definitely cool
, let's see, maybe we can solve
a problem with social media, so to speak, if you have
an inh  old debate you make it
seem unsympathetic very quickly so
if she just says hey coconut blossom sugar
is healthy or I don't say that
like that then if I say something like
that we'll definitely stay tuned that
's just now also here
in Hamburg zack based one  very, very
crazy story is going so fast
now that this year over 300 million
next year then I assume with
the dynamics when it's towards 500
million sales in 23
that would be demanding but yes
I'll take the claim with me
yes, and that wasn't no, but of course we
still have to now. The
answer to the question is we
we have to present structures in the company now
and not growth
because right now it's more important that we
have around 3 weeks, so we're not
we are not good at
different must be good we do not deliver fast
enough we are always sold out and that
is  of course also cool for the business
model but that's not cool
as fast as we are sometimes
sold out for 3 minutes now on Sunday at
11 a.m.
it can be quite so it makes a
difference whether you say hey you
somehow have five hours where something is
available  and then a limited
edition just expired or just
four minutes and 80% of the customers get
nothing so that's just [ __ ]
always done the job or
something like that then according to these
drops but simply permanently so there
are different aspects too
on this topic ne, for example, with the
junkie it's clever and it's great
fun to develop new tastes at the
same time if you eventually have 18
varieties you have an incredible
complexity and we always want to
produce fresh products because in the
end it's still half a food
ne that is  Yes, there are vegetable
fibers and fruit in it, which is
always better when it's fri  sch is and
that means from this aspect we want to do
work with limited editions
and the goal is
that they are not available for 7 minutes
but for five hours then you still
have this topic that you know okay it
's kind of like that too  a bit
exclusive and no, we can always
develop new tastes, but
the customers really manage
to get the product and that's the
problem, and I can understand that
some people are very, very
disappointed if they stick with it for a
week  we see a product we are
really looking forward to it or at Amazon
we get real problems then
ranking but sometimes there
are other dealers and then he
drives absurd blossoms that then
we launch our product for what
I know 30 euros then it is sold out
after five minutes you have three hours
later on Amazon some dealers
who offer it for 80 euros such as
advent calendars  We sold r for 100 euros
, also with a lot of products
in them and they somehow sell for 170
on ebay,
so if they're just good, insofar as you
're right that's cool, but we
actually want to be able to control
it better and that a drop is sold out is
okay  but if you are now a protein customer
who just
wants to have his protein regularly that
sucks if the problem is so if
you say that a product I want for
my health and then
you don't get it that's cool
and
okay  there's a lot to do but there's still
an exciting story so at the latest
I don't know sometime in 24
months maybe when the stock market
starts to improve again then the IPO will come
then I'd like
to meet you here somehow for the podcast we'll
stay in touch,
all right yes  so I press thank
you very much thank you for the detailed
narrative so I don't think you've heard that before, so
I find it impressive
thank you very much thank you for everything clear
ciao ciao
[music]